foreign
[Music]
while on a six and a half hour spacewalk
on the International Space Station in
2017 astronauts Peggy Whitson and Shane
Kimbrough experienced a bit of
clumsiness that would pose no problems
on Earth but can cause some major
headaches in space they dropped a piece
of debris Shield that was part of the
docking porse a fabric covering that
weighed 8 kilograms and measured 162
centimeters by 59 centimeters about the
size of a carrador and that debris
Shield had an important role to play it
was supposed to cover a docking port on
the ship protecting it from extreme
temperature changes and orbital debris
something the ISS could not do it out
the shield was a Whipple Shield that
uses the hyper velocity of space debris
to its advantage using thin layers of
Shield to obliterate the debris into
tiny fragments that the inner Shield can
withstand as the energy of the debris is
spread out over a larger distance
back on Earth the mission control team
got to work thanks to the fact that they
had replicas of everything in space
every night in Bolt And every piece of
fabric Mission Control found a way for
Whitson and Kimbrough to use wire ties
and a different piece of cloth as a
substitute for the Lost Whipple Shield
until a replacement could be sent up on
another rocket having dealt with the
problem there was one more thing to
worry about whether that lost piece of
Shield would come slamming back into the
space station The Shield was monitored
closely for two orbits before it was
determined that there was no risk it
would hit the ISS Kimbrough and Whitson
could breathe the sigh of relief and
Whitson could properly celebrate having
completed the most spacewalks of any
woman but just how common is it for
astronauts to lose grip on tools and
other objects while in the microgravity
of space how costly are these brief
bouts of Butterfingers on the ISS and
what happens if the newly made space
debris is on a collision course with the
station or another light these are all
scenarios NASA and the astronauts
themselves have to prepare for like
anything else sometimes accidents happen
the Lost Shield wasn't the first time
astronauts have lost something in the
swirl of space while conducting an extra
vehicular activity or spacewalk in 2006
astronaut Pier seller dropped a spatula
while doing work on the space station
and apparently had a lot of spatulas
waiting for him in his office when he
came back to Earth after the mission
that same year another astronaut lost a
camera and in 2008 another astronaut was
dealing with a grease gun explosion when
she lost a tool bag
[Applause]
we have a lost foreign
part of the reasons items can become
lost is because of the challenge of
maneuvering small objects while wearing
massive gloves astronaut Drew feustel
has gone to space three times for a
total of 226 days and conducted nine
spacewalks accumulating the second
longest amount of Eva time among U.S
astronauts he's pretty familiar with the
difficulty of doing work in a bulky 160
kilogram spacesuit I equate it to uh to
wearing a set of mechanics gloves with
welding gloves on top you know that's
how it feels getting tactile feedback
through your fingertips and through your
hands it's not really a good way to
train that except to expose yourself to
that environment and the way NASA has
astronauts practice in advance of going
to space is by wearing their suits in a
massive pool which has a precise
Recreation of the ISS built underwater
for the astronauts to practice on they
learn how to maneuver in their suits how
to manipulate tools for repair work how
to move objects from one area to another
and how to perform an emergency rescue
on team members all while still on the
planet it's a pretty good analog but not
everyone gets as much time to practice
as they might like historically during
the shuttle era space shuttle era when
we're flying to space we would train
about a 10 to 1 ratio meaning we'd
practice a technique or a task uh 10
times underwater for every single time
we saw in space so for every hour of
work and space we'd we'd have about 10
hours under in the pool underwater
training those tasks and that allows you
to really build that knowledge of what
you can expect the feedback to be
through your hands as you're working
with the objects in space we we see much
less of that now we're probably closer
to a two to three to one ratio if that
so it's more difficult to have that
exposure and it becomes a challenge the
astronauts have a number of safeguards
for themselves and all their Hardware
once they're out outside the station
doing an Eva they're always attached to
small tethers on retractable reels that
are either 17 meters or 26 meters long
which will self-retract allowing the
astronauts to move around without fear
of drifting too far on top of that they
have small local tethers that only
extend about 1.5 meters which keep them
close enough to the station that they
can use both hands for specific
activities but they still have a little
more room to maneuver then there are all
the other tethers for the tools bags and
whatever other gear they might be
carrying
we always attempt to make sure that
every single item that goes outside of
the airlock with us has some attachment
to something and that's achieved through
those tethers we are not always
successful in uh in keeping those
tethers attached and it's always a
little bit scary when you find yourself
holding an object and you realize that
there's no tether attached to it either
because it was bumped off or it came off
accidentally or in some cases it was
never attached in the first place I've
had a couple of experiences with holding
items that didn't have tethers on that I
expected to have tethers on and those
are the times when you very carefully
reached out and find a tether somewhere
anywhere to connect back to that thing
bus on one particular occasion during
his ninth spacewalk in March 2018 foist
lost hold of an object he'd been working
to install cameras and wireless
communication equipment next to a
docking port as well as curing a loose
component on a solar array blanket box
when he lost a wire tie what he
describes as something like a big
garbage tie when he pulled the tether to
which the wire was attached it turned
out the jaws of it were still open and
the tide quickly floated away there have
been crew members in the past who have
lunged after objects you could maybe do
that if you have a short tether on
you're not going to Lunge very far if
you have a long tether on and you lunge
you're going to travel for another 55 or
85 feet before that tether hopefully
stops you from your motion and you may
or may not have been successful at
reaching the object that is now floating
away from you but in my case I was
attached to a foot restraint which means
my feet were fixed there was really no
way for me to move and I simply watched
this object once I realized it was gone
just float away from me and and at that
time all you can really do is call
mission control and say I've lost an
object and this is what it was and this
is how how large it is and this is the
direction it's trying traveling and this
is how fast I think it's going and then
that data gets reported to our tracking
officers at Mission Control and then and
then that gets reported pretty much
around uh you know the entire
um space uh debris Network which exists
not only the us but internationally to
track items that are floating in space
that are not
really controlled in any way just as
with the piece of drop shield in 2017
NASA had to closely monitor the
trajectory of the little wire tie and in
this case despite the object being much
smaller it ended up being more of a
problem what I was told after my uh the
loss of my wire tie is that for the
first time in history
a satellite had to change its orbital
altitude because of a free-floating
object in space for fear of damage to
satellite and that object was my wire
tie that I had lost was floating around
and was had an impending collision with
some some type of satellite that was
important to somebody and they actually
had to change the orbital altitude of
that satellite in order to create a
greater distance or Miss Miss distance
between between those two objects and
something as small as a wire tie could
could destroy an entire module on the
space station or even cause you know and
cause catastrophic damage to any piece
of equipment in space of course this
issue with debris goes far beyond a few
mishaps with astronauts losing hold of
things while on Eva NASA has a pretty
good track record on the vast majority
of spacewalks everything that's carried
out is carried back inside the real
problem is that debris has been
accumulating in orbit around Earth ever
since the Space Race began with the
launch of Sputnik in 1957. By 1979
debris from satellites and failed
Rockets were already posing enough of a
problem that NASA created the orbital to
pre-program to monitor the accumulating
number of small objects that could cause
damage to spacecraft this program uses a
network of ground-based and space-based
observation techniques like the U.S Air
Force Space surveillance Network which
can keep track of larger objects in
space while ground-based Raider like the
Goldstone solar system radar can detect
much smaller objects of course it would
be in possible to keep track of all the
debris today there are 23 000 objects
larger than a softball orbiting Earth
half a million one centimeter size
fragments and over 100 million micro
fragments that are one millimeter or
slightly larger so computer models have
been developed to log and track space
debris which alerts controllers when a
collision becomes a threat and allows
avoidance Maneuvers to be performed the
ISS has a risk management system when a
potential Collision is detected the ISS
has an imaginary box drawn around it 50
kilometers squared and 0.75 kilometers
deep this acts as an exclusion Zone and
any track debris that could pass through
it will send an alert to Mission Control
from there careful risk analysis begins
if there is a one in ten thousand to one
in one hundred thousand chance of
collision the ISS receives a yellow
warning which means flight controllers
must perform avoidance Maneuvers if they
do not interfere with mission objectives
that can be as simple as interfering
with microgravity experiments if there
is a greater than one in ten thousand
risk then a red warning is received and
the International Space Station must
take action regardless of mission
objectives these exclusion zones exist
for all satellites in NASA database for
example in March 29 2012 an automated
email alert was sent to the Fermi gamma
race-based telescope team informing them
of a predicted incursion between Fermi
and Cosmos 1805 a retired Russian spy
satellite where the two would pass
within 200 meters of each other forcing
them to abandon their mission
temporarily and point their thrusters
which were designed to de-orbit the
satellite in the direction of travel
performing a one second burn to prevent
a potential Collision
even the smallest bits of debris like a
piece of paint travel at speeds fast
enough to do serious damage if they hit
a rocket or the ISS and tracking debris
this mall is impossible which is why we
need debris Shields like the one dropped
in 2017 which ironically became debris
itself however the debris Shield was a
relatively large and light object
helping it deorbit quicker as
atmospheric drag still exists at this
altitude forcing the ISS to perform
regular boost Burns to maintain its
orbit foisel says it's also much harder
to lose heavier objects while working
outside the space station you know for a
large object that weighs 800 pounds if
you let go of it with no tether on it
it's not going to go anywhere even if
you bump it with your hand it's not
going to go anywhere because you can't
put enough Force into it to actually
move it but something like a wire tie
which is a small metal wire that's super
easy that if you just flick it with your
fingertips or bump it that thing's just
going to go cruising away much faster
than you can reach out and grab it thus
it's not only the risk of collision that
causes problems when an astronaut loses
something in space there's also the
issue of whether or not that tool had
Replacements on the space station
consider the Lost Shield again something
that weighs 8 kilograms doesn't sound
very large but when you factor in the
cost of rocket launches every kilo
counts at least in the case of the wire
tie forced to Lost there were others
available on the space station and
ultimately the Rogue wiretie didn't
cause any damage though Foy still says
it can still be a little blow to an
astronaut's perfect record you lose
style points for losing things in space
it's probably possible to find this out
to do a web search and find out when I
lost my wiretad I remember saying
something like well I'm going to have to
live with this for the rest of my life
knowing that I dropped something in
space because up until that point I had
a pretty good record I had gone without
dropping anything at all and then this
this last Act of Misfortune was was my
contribution to items floating in space
they shouldn't be so it's it's more of a
style thing nobody looks dead doesn't
reflect negatively I don't think on your
space space walking career but it's
certainly uh something that we all
strive to not do and you don't want to
be the person who's constantly losing
things in fact if you were somebody who
constantly lost things both in training
and in space you probably wouldn't be
doing space walks out out on on orbit
dropping a tool in space is not
something any of us have to worry about
on a daily basis but having the right
tool for the job and knowing how to use
it can make or break a project keysight
put the very best tools in Engineers
hands and are holding a virtual event
for electrical engineers and science
enthusiasts on the 14th of March that's
three days from now so sign up quickly
with the link in the description this
fantastic free event is a rare
opportunity to learn about Electronics
from experts the event on the 14th will
discuss common circuit board rules of
thumb and test them with keysight's
modern tools for example what happens to
the electrical performance of a 50 ohm
circuit board Trace when it's dipped in
liquid nitrogen they'll compare their
real world board measurements to
simulations and dig into Concepts every
electrical engineer should understand
this isn't just a live video you can
watch and learn from there will be a q a
session too allowing you to ask industry
experts questions and everyone that
registers for the event will be entered
into a draw for keysight's massive gear
giveaway they are giving away 20 pieces
of pro-grade test gear including 6
gigahertz 8 channel oscilloscopes these
are extremely valuable professional
grade tools and you'll get an extra
entry to the giveaway if you sign up
with my link if you missed this event
don't worry because you can re-watch the
stream and they will be holding new Live
Events every two months with the next
event planned for May 16th whether
you're an expert engineer or Electronics
newbie you should definitely be signing
up for this completely free event